[موسيقى
] لعنة بونتا كانا يجلس واحدًا
من أكثر المتاحف الفريدة في البلاد وهو
متحف مليء بالتاريخ والحياة ،
ولا يمكن العثور عليه إلا على ارتفاع 20 قدمًا تحت الماء ، حيث
يتمتع الغواصون بفرصة استكشاف
حطام سفينة من القرن السابع عشر حيث تقع داخل
الشعاب المرجانية في منطقة البحر الكاريبي  في هذا المتحف
الحي للبحر ، تم افتتاح المتحف في
مايو من عام 2019 ومنذ ذلك
الحين اكتشف الزوار أصدافًا مرجانية نادرة
والسلاحف والأسماك أثناء التنقل حول
مراسي المدافع وغيرها من القطع الأثرية من
حطام سفينة تاريخية ، المنطقة
محمية من الصيد التجاري
والغوص غير الترفيهي  تحافظ القيود
على التراث البحري وتساعد على
زيادة أعداد الأسماك.المتحف هو
مجرد رحلة قصيرة بالقارب والغطس تحت الماء
بعيدًا عن الساحل ، إنه ليس
موقع غوص ترفيهي فحسب ، بل يُظهر أيضًا
تاريخًا غنيًا وبيولوجيا مزدهرة
في جمهورية الدومينيكان